ce mercredi 1er novembre ne déroge pas à
la règle comme tous les jours marine
taulé 29 ans vient avec le sourire pour
sa session de boxe quotidienne dans
cette salle d'elancourt
une passion que la boxeuse originaire de
jouars-pontchartrain pratique depuis
l'âge de 7 ans voulaient plus beaucoup
plus jeune père du foot
sauf qu'à l'époque le foot féminin
n'était pas aussi réputés que maintenant
et mes parents ne voulaient pas et ils
sont 10 quitte à faire un sport de
garçons autant haute enfin quelque chose
qui va te servir qu elle permet de
défendre pour papa de faire de la boxe à
21 en libye noise décide de passer un
palier de rejoindre la team farruggia
mais des meilleures équipes de france
qui compte notamment dans ses rangs le
champion d'europe marine petit et
surtout temps guy farrugia un entraîneur
réputé dans le monde de la boxe
je n'ai pas accueilli les bras ouverts
je soutiens quelques problèmes avec les
filles qui a eu avant dont on a comme on
appelle ça on a eu je n'ai pas accueilli
je lui dis bien va taper dans leurs
inquiétudes mais je m'en occuperai pas
de toi et elle a réussi à s'intégrer à
pousser les murs et à faire partie de la
team en quelques mois mais bon elle
avait réussi à se donner à fond tout
simplement un duo qui fonctionne
encadrés par tanguy farrugia marine
remporté dix victoires en douze combats
de boxe amateur des résultats qui l'ont
poussé à s'inscrire chez les
professionnels premier combat ce samedi
11 9 ans au vélotour national de saint
quentin en yvelines dans la catégorie
moins de 57 kg la boxeuse affrontera la
niçoise nahid kharchi championne du
monde pieds poings
l'objectif c'est de remporter le
combattrons tous les boxeurs ont pour
objectif comme sur un ring c'est de
gagner le combat
après avant la limite
dans les temps au point peu importe que
l'idée c'est d'y aller à 160 250 % même
de ses capacités d'y aller à fond on ne
peut pas y aller à moitié cette dernière
mise de gants de s'y rendent au palais
des sports dit long cours a laissé
entrevoir de belles promesses mais le
contexte sera différent dans quelques
jours devant des milliers de spectateurs
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines